oh i got my second coven shot
and i feel terrible
like i feel so awful right now like i
don't want to do anything like all i
want to do is sleep and sleep and sleep
um
like it's just
just lethargy man it's just like
i'm not doing anything it's it's wild
man like it's wild
but i took the second dose of the
vaccine so you guys don't have to so
that if i
if i turn into a lizard person uh or i
mutate and become the incredible hulk
then you guys will know
stay away from the vaccine i'm specimen
but
uh as you guys could tell i sound pretty
rough um
i am in no condition to make videos so
uh so because of that i'm not going to
be uploading anything today it's like 3
40 already if it's not
my rule of thumb usually if it's not
like 5 p.m eastern it usually doesn't go
up sometimes there's an exception though
it kind of depends
okay scratch that rule right because i
want you guys just like ignoring my
channel after 5 p.m eastern
uh that would suck for me um so no
videos today nobody else tomorrow
um i feel awful
this is how it ends guys this is how it
ends for comics explained
it's been a good run it's been cool i
got to meet some of you guys some of you
guys got robbed poor rings
the rest of you guys
it's been it's been good
i look so pitiful i am so pitiful right
now you know this you know like here's
the thing here's the thing right first
world problems right that's
basically what this is like i'm like
inconvenienced right now you know like
it's like
it's like people who have iphones but
say they're poor right it's like you're
you're first world poor
so uh okay i'm trying to figure out what
to do with my office
right like i'm trying to figure out what
to do with this thing like i have no
idea
i mean i'm not doing anything now but i
have no idea what to do with this
like how to set this up i am going to
set up a green screen which is going to
be fun
um and probably goof off with a green
screen like talk to myself
i don't really know i have no idea but
regardless of the situation
um yeah
it's rough it's rough y'all
um one of those weird things man anyway
i want to make you guys aware of what
was going on i will catch you all later
peace